ami yann moix est avec nous ce soir
écrivain et chroniqueur je suis très
heureux qu'ils fassent partie bien sûr
de mes équipes merci anne d'être là ce
soir et c'est vrai que toi aussi tu as
vécu une tornade médiatique à un moment
c'est vrai que on s'est dit et on n'en a
pas parlé souvent tous les deux c'est
vrai qu'on se sent bien seul dans ces
moments là
disons que le 21e siècle a une
particularité c'est que au xxème siècle
qu'on avait loulou ouais aujourd'hui on
a toujours le who's who mais c'est un
who's who malveillance et vous ou de la
haine c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle
très mauvaise nouvelle c'est que tout ce
qui passe à la télé même si pour
présenter les chiffres et les lettres où
la météo auront une polémique un jour
c'est la mauvaise nouvelle la bonne
c'est que un mois deux mois trois mois
plus tard il ne restera rien c'est ça
aussi le 21e siècle mais il est vrai que
lorsque la tourmente et là que vous avez
des chiens aux basques avant que les
mouches ne changent d'âne et bien vous
regardez dans votre calepin qui sont les
amis qui au reste j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance je dois le dire non seulement
aucun ami ne m'a manqué
les amis en fait c'est comme le vin
pluies sont vieux puits sont solides
mais je m'en suis fait des nouveaux dont
vous par exemple cirysiens et donc c'est
vrai que c'est d'une violence inouïe
dans l'impression d'être dans un
lavomatic à l'intérieur à la place du
linge et ça secoue et ça secoue on
allume la télévision on voit sa tête on
allume la radio on entend son nom alors
évidemment les gens qui
s'immisce dans ce brouhaha et qui vous
disent tu es mon ami je t'aime on fera
de la télévision comme vous ou d'autres
qui sont toujours fidèles au rendez vous
on s'aperçoit d'une certaine manière que
ça n'a pas de prix amitié et c'est
quelque chose dont on se rend pas compte
tant qu'on n'a pas éprouvé alain delon
disais que l'amitié ça consistait à
vérifier si un ami si quelqu'un pouvait
cacher le cadavre que vous veniez de
cesser de faire à 4 heures du matin oui
c'est ça l'amitié quand bernard défendre
ses amis bien sûr il a mille fois raison
temps et même et j'ai même beaucoup plus
loin si c'est son ami et qu'il a
véritablement comme isc qu'on l'accuse
d'avoir commis ce qu'il faut être très
prudent avant deux
bernard tout à fait raison de dire oui
ben son amitié je la conserverai mon
amitié on ne choisit pas les amis en
fonction de la morale c'est la morale
n'a rien à voir avec l'amitié l'amitié
c'est quelque chose qui échappe à tous
les registres il ya quelque chose parce
que c'était lui parce que c'était moi
c'est pas rationnel il
ya beaucoup d'amis enfin que tu croyais
tes amis quittent ont tourné le dos non
plus non pour pas du tout le seul ami
qui m'a tourné le dos j'ai appris qu'en
fait il était dans la tourmente il a
déclenché cette tourmente avec mon frère
donc en fait oui c'est un fait ça c'est
pas vrai n'hésitez pas un ami c'est un
traître voilà exactement mais n'ont
aucun aucun aucun après on a des plus ou
moins courageuse terre qui attendent 24
heures aux 44 ans de 48 heures mais ça
c'est humain après il se rattrape mais
il faut la garder l'espoir toujours oui
mais parce que ben quand été de dire que
honnêtement il ya quelque chose de
terrible dans ces cas là c'est qu'on se
demande véritablement si ce qui nous
arrive est vrai c'est irréel les hommes
politiques sont habitués à voir ça les
hommes d'état les hommes publics mais un
écrivain un artiste un acteur le
présentateur on n'est pas fait pour ça a
priori est ce qui vous si vous voulez
dans mon cas il y avait un truc terrible
j'avais fait ces caricatures il ya
trente ans mais il ya quelque chose
d'horrible
dans mon cas précis c'est que quand bien
même ces bandes dessinées et est abject
et reconnue et rejoint ici l été
si vous voulez y avait précédé
prescrites par la loi or le système
médiatique a décidé que la prescription
n'existait pas c'est à dire plutôt que
de dire quand même ce type il aurait pu
devenir fasciste avec la famille
d'extrême droite qu'il avait plutôt que
de regarder le parcours que j'avais fait
était le contraire de ce que j'avais été
programmé pour être on a préféré me
ramener dans une case 30 ans en arrière
alors que toute la journée on fait
l'apologie des gens dans les banlieues
etc mais pas que dans les banlieues qui
partent de rien et qui arrive à s'élever
de manière contraire aux idéaux qu'ils
avaient reçu à la base il ya plutôt que
de dire [ __ ] ce mec il a évolué on m'a
remis 30 ans en arrière ça pour me
résigner à ce que j'avais failli devenir
et donc mes amis étant intelligent pour
la plupart ils disaient bien choisis et
peut-être qu'ils m'ont - bien choisis
que moi je les ai choisis et bien ils
n'ont pas été dupes ce que je veux dire